well thanks this is a great opportunity
to be here it's been a lot of fun
listening to all the history of the
profession a lot of stuff that we've
heard before and a lot of new details
that I actually didn't know so it's
really great and thank you all for that
I wanted to give you a quick little
update regarding the a APA in the PA
profession so we know about the history
and the first students being military
cores men in addition now currently
there are 75,000 clinically practicing
pas big difference in a few years ago
we'll talk a little bit about the trends
within the demographics of the
profession specifically that 64% of the
profession is now women and the average
salary is eighty-nine thousand dollars
that's a great opportunity for the
profession as well I could think back
when I applied to PA school and if I
should say the first time I applied to
PA school I played three times to get
into the child health associate PA
program in Denver Colorado each time
they gave me something else to do right
so the first time they said well you
really don't have any healthcare
experience what are you gonna do to make
that better well what did I do
I went and I volunteered and I worked at
an Easter Seals camp and then I came
back the next time and they said wow you
did that but how do you know you want to
take care of children Easter Seals camp
children handicapped I thought that
covered it
No so then the next time that I applied
I was wait-listed by the way so I do
have a little redeeming factor there the
final time that I applied to the PA
program dr. Henry silver who was the
program director who scared the living
hell out of me quite frankly as a
student and liked him a lot
after during the program said to me if
you become a physician assistant the
child health associate are you gonna
take care of patients are you gonna be
one of those administrative type no of
course taking care of patients why else
would I want to be a physician assistant
and interestingly that's a very
different perspective nowadays because
we need patient care individuals but we
need administrators and that's one of
the real challenges that we'll see in
the next several years for the
profession so when we look at the PA
profession over the last 45 years 43 %
hold master's degree and now 40 % hold a
bachelor's degree today's economy with a
issue that are going on with the budgets
around the world the PA profession has
had a stellar several years forbes.com
list the physician assistant master's
degree as the number one master's degree
to obtain to me that deserves a round of
applause
plenty of accolades CNN Money Magazine
us World News report as well as Kipling
jerk the US Bureau of Labor and
Statistics projects that the PA
profession is a second growing health
care profession and we're actually gonna
have a 39% growth during that time frame
Money Magazine listing the PA profession
in the top 50 jobs this is Robert Wooten
who happens to be our incoming
president-elect and he'll take over the
President on presidency in June 10th of
this year and looking at that
opportunity from what we heard before of
not having an identity it is clear what
our identity is right now and I think
that's really an exciting time looking
at this when we talk about the PA
workforce when we look at 1969 to 1972
it was clear we were small potatoes
however by 2011 they'll be 85 thousand
six hundred and six graduates PA from PA
programs you'll see in 1999 is actually
when we saw the chip shift there from
primarily women it was really a fifth
know about 50 40 or 50 60 50 60 it was
primarily 5050 close you can see all
that way but then it really did change
in 1999 is when we saw that shift so
from those years that we talked about
what did pas do and pas have
prescriptive privileges and the ability
to practice now all 50 states authorized
pas to practice and prescribe where you
have the NCCP exam that we talked about
was so much of a challenge to begin now
70 4329 are certified by the NC CPA and
the app they mean salary is 93 thousand
and we expect to have over 103 thousand
by pas by 2018
that's a stellar growth this just
demonstrates that growth as we continue
to look at our mean salary now this is
starting in 1995 you know
in 1973 I'm not real sure what the
average salary was for a PA that was you
go girl hoops well the other ones put
twelve thousand fourteen oh you good
girls eleven fifteen eighteen Bruce what
did you make
oh man you know the specialty pas always
make more and they want to hide it a
little bit we'll work on that so now
this is the mean annual income for pas
who graduated in 2008 and you can see
the average salary is anywhere from
seventy eight seventy five to seventy
eight thousand with the emergency
medicine being the highest internal
medicine seventy six Pediatrics
seventy-five so we look at the 2009 data
it's actually very similar at the PA new
graduates income with emergency medicine
again being the highest followed by
dermatology and surgery now that's not
really surprising what's more surprising
is that pas and emergency medicine are
making around 85 to 87 thousand still
alright so in any time when the economy
is poor that perfet the economy is
having difficulty the profession is
skyrocketing so where do we all practice
mainly hospitals group practices and a
small percentage in solo practice is the
other areas are going to be a real
challenge for us which will break into
shortly here but rural community centers
only eight point four percent that's a
challenge for us it's a real issue
looking at the Kaleidoscope one here
again hospital medicine looking at
multi-specialty physician groups as the
main areas that people practice in solo
practitioners this actually just breaks
it down into much more specific
freestanding surgical center
and corrective healthcare systems so
small numbers in certain areas that
overall but at a huge impact when we
looked at specialty practice dermatology
3.8% emergency medicine 10.3 and family
medicine which some people would say it
was not really a specialty it's kind of
a funny place to place it however it's
24.4%
now in doing this we part I partly we
partly set this up because many people
will say specialty medicine and that
piays are only going into specialty
medicine family practice many would
consider that as a specialty nowadays
which is a challenge but we do present
it out so that physician organizations
see a pas practicing and family medicine
as well Pediatrics and others Wow
so primary care is family practice
internal medicine and pediatrics so as
we see that number number has plummeted
and as that number plummets the number
of specialty pas at work in any
specialty is the opposite all right
so clearly we follow physicians we
follow money right we're not any
different than other groups now others
may try to define what the PA profession
is as a result of this we have organiz
organized medicine and other groups
saying that shooting PA is only work in
hospitals they don't do primary care not
true but you can understand how they can
say that this is going to be one of our
huge and the biggest challenge and
probably the most surprising issue to
everybody across the board so we look at
the US federally employed pas in 2009
and we know that the federal government
employs 8.2 percent of PAS and that the
Department of Veterans Affairs is the
largest single largest employer of PAS
in the United States with 28.6% all
right many different sections of the
government as well
so where are pas the red is the highest
concentration area with the light colors
being least concentration of EA's where
they practice keep in mind where those -
those three areas are for the PAS who
have the lightest color there because
then when we look at pas by counties in
the United States the blue area has no
PA in that County and you can see
Mississippi Alabama being major areas of
concerns and huge areas and blocks so
this is according to when you register
and you give us the a a PA information
and NCC PA information about where you
practice now is it a hundred percent
no because really I live in New York
State but I practice in Connecticut so
if you're gonna say where is my where am
i registered it may not be a hundred
percent but it's a pretty good indicator
so we have large gaps again the
distribution of physician assistants is
a major concern just like that for
physicians
so it was briefly talked about advocacy
and how everyone had to kind of promote
the PA profession at the very early
years it hasn't changed even if you
don't support healthcare reform the role
of the AAP a is to support the aspect
within healthcare reform that's going to
allow you to practice medicine and take
care of your patients so within
healthcare reform we are able to get a
15% carve-out for PA educational
programs in funding primary care
medicine we also receive 32 million in
PA education between 2010 and 2014 and
it will fund the stipends of educational
expenses living expenses and indirect
cost up to $22,000 per student within
healthcare reform for the PA provisions
a 10% Medicare bonus for selected
primary care codes furnished via PA and
remember within the healthcare reform
bill pas are listed as primary care
providers a very important aspect that
was not there before and that should
really be a round of applause for the
Academy successfully passed
and some of the other things that have
been you know put out there before as a
provisions about effective 2011 to 2015
the Medicare codes and getting some
reimbursement for that as well
specifically so a snapshot of our
current status so pas as you all know
are authorized to prescribe in all 50
states a big change from what we heard
about at the beginning of this
discussion all 50 states puts DC and
territories except Puerto Rico or have
prescribing rights and we are working on
Puerto Rico by the way we have
individuals in the room that have been
helpful for that as well the Academy
actually was just down in Puerto Rico
about three weeks ago in talking with
different legislators and getting some
enabling legislation to have APA
practice act so we're gonna see where
that goes in the next six months or so
48 states allow you to including DC and
Guam for controlled substances now the
two states said don't Kentucky in
Florida now on that advocacy point we
talked about the six key elements that
the Academy believes are going to be
practice acts within the state that are
going to allow pas to have better
practice in order to practice Act in
order to take care of their patients and
they're listed here licensure as a
regulatory term physician authorization
to delegate prescriptive authority to
include scheduled drugs scope of
practice to be determined at the
supervising physician the PA and any
relevant facility requirements adaptable
supervision requirements no co-signature
requirement is determined by the
practice area and no ratio limit hmm we
see these are the main issues that have
been limiting practice acts were
throughout the United States in all the
different states so when we look at that
there is one state that meets all six
Rhode Island
a little bitty guy right but clearly we
have room for improvement and this is
November 2008 so we have continued to
make improvement and now you see that
again respect and now you see that one
other state North Dakota has joined the
ranks so the number of provisions having
Crete I've improved by of Newton
November of 2010 when we look at state
laws making improvements to the PA laws
and regulation this is that there's 35
different states here that have made
improvements to their state laws that's
a good number so they're making
improvements they're looking at those
six key elements to move us forward
States with improvements in those laws
actually this is the one with 35
different states made those improvements
significantly so we're really happy with
that over the last two years so getting
the word out the Academy's job is really
to promote the PA profession across the
board to all healthcare legislators
hospital administrators insurers so if
there's questions or concerns that's my
job and that's our job individually as
well so within healthcare reform we were
talking about how long do Americans have
to wait these ads were actually in the
Congressional quarterly and publications
within the Capitol was in the Capitol
area and at fill region members of
Congress make it as make it as easy to
care for someone dying as it is to care
for someone living we have some
legislation federal legislation that I
can take care of a patient their entire
life but when it comes to end-of-life
care I can't order that now if I'm in
rural Montana that's a challenge to get
end-of-life care at the most important
time of a families care for that time
frame to get that care and to delay that
care when
needed the most so this was an ad to
educate legislators now we go to Capitol
Hill regularly and we recently had our a
hill visit that was in February where we
had over 250 pas that came to the hill
and they lobbied on behalf of the
profession we have three other
organizations we have the American
Academy of Family Practice PAS
dermatology pas coming as well would
they'll have around 400 individuals
coming to those conferences and they'll
have a lobbying and legislative
component to that as well
to talk about healthcare issues for
physician assistants in their specialty
areas as well as things like this so
getting the word out transforming care
is a big job we should know we're doing
it every day we're really challenged
with many aspects within the federal and
legend state legislation but we've made
great strides as you saw before from the
very beginning when we did not have
certification we did not have state
enabling legislation that allowed us to
practice it's clear that we have those
now they need to be improved and those
six key elements are the ones that we
have chosen as an a professional
organization to move us forward because
those are the areas that are real issues
for us so challenging misconceptions if
there's anything that I think we do that
members appreciate the most is when
there's a problem in their Hospital
within their region that the Academy can
help them I received a call from an
individual from Michigan stating that
there is a billboard placed up on the
highway that said if you come to this
regional center you'll only see doctors
interesting concept because it was
really between do two different regional
medical centers and it had nothing to do
with the quality care patient care or
anything else right it was a marketing
ploy that was used by the hospital hey
PA stepped in within two weeks this was
taken off and removed as well as an
apology letter to the PAS in the state I
think that is an amazing opportunity for
us
I don't know how many people saw the
today's show dr. Nancy Snyderman who by
the way has been to our a APA conference
but her point of reference when she
spoke at our conference was in the mid
to late 80s what was happening in the
mid to late late 80s we were still
challenged with many of our practice
laws and some prescriptive issues she
made a grave error in saying that pas
cannot prescribe and within 15 minutes
I'm getting calls from the Academy from
mem and members saying did you see
all right I'm like god no I'm seeing
patients all right but yeah I took the
afternoon off to deal with a lot of the
public relations issues that were as a
result of this now this was a real
challenge for us because not only do we
need to get a correction and we have a
written correction Facebook Corrections
other things like that but we also are
investigating now a not a real public
apology because not money need to get an
apology from her but my need is to
utilize this as an educational
opportunity within NBC to have a APA pas
within the state and to get on the NBC
Today Show and or dr. Nancy Snyderman
has a whole educational program that's
all about medicine so we're looking at
those avenues and those are real
challenges but without having a strong
background that you guys have planted
for us and moved us forward this would
never have been the possibility so I'm
very unhappy that this happened but
we're trying to make every positive
benefit for this would you become a PA
eighty-eight percent says yes I think
that has a great opportunity and
challenge for us when we look at the
healthcare landscape and we look at
other physician partners not everyone
would be able to say that they have a
success rate and please rate that they
would get back into that profession
again in fact we are the only profession
that has this rate at this high
so I'd be happy to answer any questions
and thank you guys so much right to the
high-tech work for electronic medical
records pas were left off of the
legislation of his physicians and nurse
practitioners and you get money for
signing up for the high-tech component
and your office or practice would get
that money so we talked about how that
affected not the money component but how
it affected patient care and patient
care access issues what's taken place as
a result of that we are having actually
two Democrat and a Republican that are
going to be introducing legislation to
I'm having to add pas to the list we
will be challenged and it's gonna be a
very difficult issue because it's not
considered budget neutral that's where
our problem is the Congressional Budget
Office wants budget neutral and it's not
a budget neutral issue but we are
challenged by it and we are following up
more details regarding it and we're
talking about it regarding access as
well one of the Connecticut PA students
was applying for a job and they said
well why would I hire the PA when I
could hire the nurse practitioner and in
addition to getting this the nurse
practitioner is going to bring this
money into the practice the PA is not so
we talked about how it affects the scope
of practice and the Billy ability of PAS
to actually have access and pasted into
patient care access was one of the major
messages there and it is going to be a
very large challenge for us